es wird ja seit ewigen Zeiten über die
Bürokratisierung über die Bürokratie
geschimpft aber wir haben wirklich eine
neue Dimension erreicht es gibt keine
größere Lüge als die von der
Entbürokratisierung die man unendlich
ins
Werk setzen will in Wirklichkeit braucht
dieser Staat und vor allem diese
Regierung so wie sie verfasst ist
braucht die Bürokratisierung es ist eine
eine Zwangsmaßnahme es ist eine Waffe
auf dem Weg zur großen Transformation
auf dem Weg zur Gesellschaftsveränderung
und deshalb wird überregulierten
Überregulierung ist nichts anderes als
Bürokratisierung in allen Bereichen
sicher auch im Bildungssystem sicher
auch im Gesundheitssystem beim Bau
einer heizungsbürokratie ganz neu
überall wird über
bürokratisiert und jede Reform jede
Reform bringt neue Regularien und bringt
eine neue Überregulierung mit dem Ziel
Wohlstand letztlich Wohlstand zu
vernichten den persönlichen
Freiheitsraum des Individuums
einzuschränken
Wohlstand soll abgeschafft werden die
Wirtschaft soll geschadet werden deshalb
reden wir lieber über ein Beispiel
immer mehr Knüppel werdende Wirtschaft
in die Beine geworfen und das ein
aktuelles Beispiel ist ein Gesetz mit
dem monströsen Titel das muss ich
ablesen ablesen Lieferketten sorgfalts
Pflichten gesetzt das zeigt schon alles
eigentlich ein moralischer Ansatz wie
alles bei diesen überregulierern eine
gute Absicht es sollen alle Lieferanten
auf der großen weiten Welt die
irgendetwas für deutsche Firmen waren
die sagen geprüft werden und
auf Herz und Nieren
gecheckt werden ob Sie nun einen Umwelt
und einen Arbeitsbedingungen nach
deutschen Maßstäben gehorchen das
bedeutet aber für jede Wirtschaft dass
sie etwas wie viele Firma dass sie etwas
garantieren und ja auch juristisch
garantieren was sie überhaupt nicht im
Griff hat ist eine Mission Impossible
niemand kann für hunderte von
Lieferanten für hunderte von Produkten
irgendwo im in Asien oder sonst wo
garantieren dass die nach unseren
Maßstäben gemacht werden aber es wird
nachgeprüft es wird verlangt und es
nützt vor allem nichts den Betroffenen
den Arbeiterinnen und Arbeitern in
Bangladesch oder sonst wo hilft das gar
nichts die einzigen die damit ein
Geschäft machen das sind Agenturen die
man jetzt braucht das sind TÜVs für
diese Dinge das sind
Anwaltsfirmen die eine eine riesige
Prozessflut die jetzt kommen wird die
daran verdienen aber die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der deutschen
Wirtschaft die wird mit Sicherheit
eingeschränkt und so sieht man das
wiederum die Bürokratie und der
Moralismus Brüder im Geistes sind
überregulierungs Wut kommt am Anfang
schon verkündet dass sie was dagegen tun
will dass sie auch Vorschriften aufheben
will dass sie entbürokrat sehen will vor
allem die FDP wirkt ja gerne damit
weniger Vorschrift Gegenteil passiert
also ihr seid die Ampel jetzt in Kraft
das ist eigentlich das Gegenteil
passiert absolut und das muss auch so
sein weil wie ich gesagt habe das ist
die Hauptwaffe bei der
Gesellschaftsveränderung das hat ja
einen legalen und eine legitimen
Anstrich das ist ja nur Recht und Gesetz
das ist ja nur Bürokratie aber in
Wirklichkeit ist die Bürokratie ein
Machtinstrument ein
Unterdrückungsinstrument so weit ist es
inzwischen und wo wird der Bürger der
von betroffen werden überall wenn er
sich eine Heizung reparieren lässt im
Keller hat das schon wieder eine riesen
Bürokratie zu tun wir haben wir haben
das komplizierteste Steuersystem der
Welt niemand fängt auch nur an drüber
nachzudenken wie man das vereinfachen
könnte diese bierdeckeldebatte die ging
ja nach hinten los der deutsche glaubt
dass da da ist sind die Bürger selber
dran schuld zum großen Teil der deutsche
glaubt ja an Recht und Ordnung und der
glaubt Ordnung habe etwas mit Staat der
einem etwas
etwas abverlangt zu tun das aber Unsinn
es gibt keine natürliche Ordnung sondern
die Ordnung ist immer nur das System das
den gerade herrschenden einfällt um das
Volk zu unterdrücken man muss es so
brutal sagen Afra Schröter weil das
nicht eigentlich immer die die Stärke
auch von Deutschland diese Liebe
Zuordnung zu Disziplinen zur Vorschrift
zum Fleiß das hat zwei Seiten auf der
einen Seite selbstverständlich und dafür
ist Deutschland im Ausland auch
bewundert worden bei uns gibt es
Qualitätsstandards der geht früher immer
gesagt die Bahn fährt pünktlich ne aber
ist aber so die Vorteile haben sich
längsten Luft aufgelöst nehmen wir die
Bahn die Bahn fährt grundsätzlich nicht
wirklich ja und andere Dinge
funktionieren auch nicht die Bürokratie
ist so angewachsen mittlerweile dass sie
ihren Zweck den sie vielleicht mal
gehabt hat nicht mehr erfüllen kann
sondern sie beschäftigt sich
grundsätzlich mit sich selbst und
wie jede Institution neigt neigt auch
die Bürokratie dazu sich immer weiter
aufzublähen und diesen Prozess haben wir
im Moment und es ist sehr schwierig so
etwas zurückzubauen leiden tut darunter
der einzelne Mensch leiden tut natürlich
auch der Mittelstand der Mittelstand
kann diese ganzen
Verfahren gar nicht mehr leisten
Lieferketten wirklich lückenlos zurück
zu verfolgen das können Großunternehmen
leisten die der eigene Abteilungen für
haben aber der Mittelstand für den
Deutschland ja ganz ganz besonders steht
der wird möglicherweise ins Ausland
gehen oder wird aufgeben da ist es gar
nicht mehr möglich den ganzen
Anforderungen hinterher zu kommen und
zudem ist es natürlich auch eine
wahnsinnige Ressourcenverschwendung man
könnte viel produktivere Dinge tun ja
produzieren wichtige Entwicklungen
machen statt sich mit äh noch stärker
eben war ja wohl war ja gefallen
Bürokratie auch als Waffe ja und da
würde ich gerne zu unserer Politik
Akteurin hier bei Bild kommen würdest du
damit gehen Sarah ich habe das noch
nicht ganz begriffen wie sie das denn
mein inwiefern das jetzt eine Waffe
gegen mich jetzt manchmal als Bürger
sein soll können Sie es noch mal
erklären ja sicher ja weil die große
Transformation uns ja alle betrifft es
geht gegen unseren Lebensstil gegen
gegen gegen das was wir immer gedacht
haben dass sei unsere normale Kultur so
wollen wir leben ja das soll uns jetzt
verboten werden Verbote kommen ohne
Bürokratie nicht aus und in dem Moment
wo etwas überreguliert wird wie bei uns
führt es ins pure Gegenteil von Ordnung
nämlich in das in diese Situation dass
gar nichts mehr funktioniert die Bahn
funktioniert ja nicht nur deshalb nicht
weil sie zu wenig Züge und zu wenig
Gleise hat sondern weil alles bis ins
letzte Detail geregelt ist ja und so ist
es in allen Bereichen
wurde schon vor zehn Jahren vorgefahren
werden
die beschaffungsbürokratie bei der
Bundeswehr hat da gibt es inzwischen
mehr mehr Leute die dafür zuständig sind
welche Unterhosen Soldaten anziehen
sollen als als Soldaten selber
also wie so eine Art Kontrollinstrumente
ja er hat schon da ein sehr
intellektuellen Punkt der eine gewisse
Wahrheit hat aber ich finde auch
Deutschland wäre gut beraten wenn es
sich auch allgemein von der Bürokratie
ein bisschen frei machen würde gerade
jetzt auch mit unserem Fachkräfteproblem
viele Menschen kommen mich nicht nach
Deutschland um hier zu arbeiten aus
diesen Gründen weil wir irgendwie
Bürokratiemonster sind und
die FDP ist auch gut beraten wenn sie
das wirklich umsetzt es wird aber lange
dauern denn die Bürokratie zu
vereinfachen das muss ja immer noch
Bürokratie da sein nur sie hat sich ja
selbst übertroffen in den letzten
Jahrzehnten es ist ja so überhaupt
bürokratisch alles und komplett für die
Normalbürger verarbeitnehmer Arbeitgeber
alles und auch Menschen die zu uns
flüchten das heißt nun Asylverfahren und
so weiter und das muss alles eigentlich
vereinfacht werden auf allen Ebenen und
da werden wir noch sehr sehr lange dafür
brauchen um dahin zu kommen
natürlich aus Brüssel die diese kranke
Bürokratie ist ohne
diese völlig Reform unfähige und
verdorbene EU nicht mehr zu begreifen
dass da die Deutschen nicht nur an der
Spitze der EU an vor dass der Freund in
Silberhorn stoßen steht dann natürlich
auch gegangen
das nennt man im Internet schon da ist
Deutschland glaube ich ganz hinten dran
was das empfangbar in Amerika rumläuft
oder Türkei das überall Empfang auf uns
auch wenn du selbst kein Internet hast
ja mit der Digitalisierung tut sich
Deutschland wirklich schwer mit anderen
Teilen der Modernisierung
strukturieren Deutsche Mark du hast ein
Meister gehabt du wusste früher okay der
kommt immer alles perfekt dann als die
EU kam dann die ganzen Ausländer von
draußen für sieben und aber 8 €
gearbeitet haben
sind wir Deutschen vielleicht zu
vorschrifts treu zu regeln treu muss man
vielleicht auch einfach mal als Bürgerin
Regeln eine Vorschrift brechen nein
deutschland hat in meinen Augen ein
Problem als ich bin Güte der Bayern ich
liebe dieses Land und Deutschland will
immer erst anderen helfen vor sich
selbst hilft
verstehst was ich meine Deutschland ist
jedem Recht machen weil wir sind ja
sogar wir sind keine Nazis mehr aber
Deutschland soll erstmal sich selbst
helfen sich erstmal wieder stark werden
in Deutschland ist nicht mehr verstanden
wie früher also wir brauchen ca 400.000
Zuwanderung pro Jahr um zu finden um zu
funktionieren
400.000 Zuwanderung pro Jahr Kinder Sex
funktioniert
einfach mal sehr nett wirklich in dieser
Aussage und willkommen weiter
wurden sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
vielen vielen Dank
Bild kämpft für Sie